[Music]
well Iggy Azalea recently made a huge
change to her own life on Wednesday the
rapper revealed on Instagram stories
that she's now the proud mama of a baby
boy writing quote I kept waiting for the
right time to say something but it feels
like the more time passes the more I
realize I'm always going to feel anxious
to share news that giant with the world
Iggy continues quote I want to keep his
life private but wanted to make it clear
he is not a secret and I love him beyond
words all happen so quickly the baby
marks Iggy's first and although she
didn't reveal the identity of her son's
father or her baby's name the fancy
rapper was last romantically linked to
playboy cardi the 29 year old singer
first sparked pregnancy rumors in
December but it was never confirmed she
went radio silent on Instagram around
that time after posting this tropical
photo on December 18th with the caption
wish you were here
although Iggy did remain pretty active
on Twitter perfection hashtag perfection
it was perfect it was very unexpected
and perfect Iggy and cardi first met in
2018 and are said to have moved in
together a few months later Fat Joe past
life and now renovates last November the
couple's Atlanta residents was robbed
according to the police incident report
jewelry was stolen from their dining
room with the total value stolen at over
$350,000 what's more Iggy & cardi made a
list of stolen items which included a
diamond engagement ring this sparked
rumors that the couple was engaged but
the 29 year old rapper quickly squashed
that thought writing on Instagram quote
never said anything about an engagement
ring etc I am not engaged
please stop involving me in this story
circulating in the media today
[Music]